بدات في المانيا اكبر مناورات جويه في
تاريخ الناتو منذ تاسيسه وبدا الناتو في
قاعده فونستروف شماليه المانيا مناورات
الدفاع الجوي 23 التي اطلقت فكرتها عام
2018 في اطار الرد على ضم روسيا لشبه
جزيره القرم في عام 2014 وقال قائد القوات
الجويه الالمانيه ان النيتو مصمم على
الدفاع عن كل شبر من اراضيه حسب تصريحه
بينما اعتبر مدير الحرس الجوي الوطني
الامريكي ان المناورات تهدف الى استكمال
الوجود الدائم للولايات المتحده في اوروبا
وتوفير تدريب على نطاق اوسع مما يجري عاده
في القاره الاوروبيه
ينضم الينا من روما اليساندرو مينوتوريزو
نائب الامين العام السابق لحلف شمال
الاطلسي مرحبا بك ما الذي يميز هذه
المناورات عن سابقاتها
هل تقصدون المناورات التي تدل في المانيا
اسبوعين ويشارك فيها اكثر من 200 طائره
وهي مناوره وتمرين مهم للغايه
وله تاثير لاي اعتداءات ممكنه لانه في
ايضا في حتى الطيران المدني سيتاثر لانه
لن يتم لكي لا يتعارض مع هذه التمرينات
وسيضم المانيا والجمهوريه التشيك وغيرها
ذكرت ان هناك رسائل موجهه من وراء هذه
المناورات لروسيا ما هي الرساله تحديدا
الى روسيا لان القضيه انتم بالطبع تعرفون
ذلك والولايات المتحده تعرف ذلك هناك حرب
عدوانيه
تشن ضد اوكرانيا وهناك توازن دقيق للغايه
هناك بعض البلدان الصغيره مثل البلدان
الاسكندنافيه التي انضمت للتو الى حلف
النيتا وبلدان البلطيق
خائفه من ان روسيا وهذا قد لا يحدث في
الضرور لكن احتمال ان تقوم روسيا بمهاجمه
المانيا او مهاجمه هذه البلدان بهذا السبب
مثل هذه التمرينات التي بدات اليوم يوم
الاثنين لاظهار ان مثل هذا العدوان سيتم
التصدي له وان نيتو اقوى من ان تتعرض
لهجوم على هذا النحو لكن طبعا هذا الامر
لم يتم تقريره اليوم بل تم تقريره قبل
خمسه اعوام في العام 2018 واحتاج الى وقت
طويل ليتم تنظيمه والقيام به هو ليس امرا
وليدا الامس بل هو مخطط له منذ خمس سنوات
وماذا عن مشاركه دول مرشحه الى عضويه
الناتو نتحدث هنا او حليفه نتحدث عن
اليابان والسويد وتحديدا السؤال عن
اليابان ماذا عن مشاركتها في هذه في هذه
المناورات وايضا ما الرساله من وراء هذه
المشاركه ولمن هي موجهه
نعم
هذا السؤال وجيه وملحه وينبغي ان نوضحه
لكي تكون كل الامور واضحه امام مشاهديكم
اليابان لن تنضم الى حلف الناتو عضويه حلف
الناتو الى تقتصر على البلدان الاوروبيه
وشمال
الاطلنطي السويد نعم وهي تنتظر
موافقه الاتراك ليتخلوا عن الفيتو الذي
يفرضوه على انضمامهم
اليابان تنضم بصفه صديقه ليس المقصود منها
ان تكون عضوا بل اظهار امام الجميع بان
اليابان صديق لدولي الحلف ولكن الرساله
الموجهه الى الصين في هذا المجال
كما تعلمون كان هناك قمه في مدريد في
يوليو 2022 قبل نحو عام من الان للمره
الاولى اربعه بلدان من المحيط الهادئ دعيت
وهي اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه واستراليا
ونيوزيلندا وبالطبع كان الغرض اظهار ان
حلف النيتو
يهتم
بوضعيه بلدان حوض المحيط الهادئ لكن بحضور
هذه البلدان هم يظهروا طبعا اذا لا ليس
المقصود منها ان تكون شركاء او اذا كان
شقراء باي درجه بهذا الحد فقط وليس درجه
العضويه بهذا الحظ هناك رساله الى الصين
مصادها بانها عليها ان تتحلى بضبط النفس
لان البلدان في منطقه المحيط
الهادئ تقف مع اوروبا وامريكا الشماليه في
حاله تضامنيه هذه هي الرساله شكرا لك من
روما اليساندرو مينوتوريزو نائب الامين
العام السابق لحلف شمال الاطلسي